a new consumer reports investigation has
uncovered serious concerns with some of
the nation's ground meat supply as
families fire up that grill this summer
consumer reports tested
351 packages of ground chicken beef
turkey and some pork from supermarkets
across the country in almost one-third
of the 75 ground chicken packages they
found the presence of salmonella yikes
they also found a strain of e coli and
ground beef earlier this year that was
so dangerous that they notified the usda
now that triggered a recall of more than
28 thousand pounds of meat in seven
western states
in a statement to cbs news the food and
safety inspection service says the
consumer reports project quote
underscores why fsis is rethinking our
existing strategy so that is more
effective in reducing salmonella
infections associated with poultry
products the national chicken council
and industry trade group tell cbs news
given that americans eat about 150
million servings of chicken every day
the vast majority of consumers are
cooking and handling chicken properly
and having a safe experience but it adds
supports modernization and technology
development to better address the food
safety challenges of today and tomorrow
the north american meat institute did
not respond to requests for comment
consumer reports deputy editor for
special projects brian vines joins us
right now good morning good morning
looking good um thank you for outdoing
me with the hair yeah i was gonna say it
looks great very few people could pull
off this look ryan from head to toes
it's a visual medium
all right well let's talk some food
right now how is this uh meat making it
into
supermarkets
ground meat is unique because unlike
cuts of chicken breast or a steak where
they're single cuts and you can cook
both sides to kill the bad stuff
one bad animal can ruin the whole bunch
it goes all in and it can literally take
one bad animal to spread these bad
bacteria and it's all ground up and
imagine you start with 50 animals one of
them has something bad by the time you
disseminate it all that's a lot of
danger out there that makes sense
now
as you report americans eat
13 billion dollars worth 13 billion
dollars worth of ground meat in
2021. so is is that a a
really large enough sample size to raise
questions about the safety of ground
meat yeah because you only tested 351
packages right right because we're a big
meat-eating country okay so is it a big
enough sample if you only test 351
packages we are comfortable with that
sample size thinking about the
distribution of the places where we
bought it and the number of packages
where we bought 351 is pretty good and
if you are in if you would really like
to know about it i encourage everyone to
go to
consumerreports.org and you can read a
pdf all about our testing and our
methodology it's all there yeah because
some people say you know you take a
sample here and it's it's indicative of
what's happening in other places that's
right true it's absolutely true from
what we've seen it's too widespread the
problems so does cooking chicken does
that reduce the risk of salmonella what
do we need to know about that every year
it seems like we talk about salmonella
salmonella is a scary word for people
yeah or cooking well it's a scary and
inconvenient thing like it can make you
sick and in some cases it can be fatal
yeah but the key is that oh 165 you stay
alive you have to get it up to 165
degrees but we really encourage folks to
say that again 160 the temperature 160
165
is that a brian
or is that oh somebody much smarter than
that
a long time ago but that's catchy 165
and it's just a lot
like you have a meat thermometer that
should be in your arsenal you should
also make sure that you have a separate
veg and meat uh cutting board and just
really it's about a continuum of
containment from the moment you buy that
ground meat product put it in that
disposable bag at the grocery store make
sure you get your meat last after you've
already shopped to make sure are those
the tips are those your tips this is
real life tips okay if you're live
before you get to the 165 start that
continuum of containment by getting that
chicken or ground meat wrapping it
keeping it segregated and really keeping
it cold fight the urge to stop at the
drive-through with 300 dollars worth of
grossman's in your back seat go home and
refrigerate that stuff okay last thing a
little off subject what's your tips for
great hair oh well it's in the gene okay
talk about it brian vines thank you so
much